hello everyone
uh welcome to today's live broadcast the
expanding role of microbiology and
anti-microbial stewardship
my name is i'm the u.s marketing manager
for identification susceptibility
testing
at bd and i'll be your moderator for
today's event
today's educational webinar is brought
to you by lab roots and sponsored by bd
for more information about bd please
visit the website
bd.com now let's get started
i'd like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time
you want during the presentation to do
so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click on the send
button
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation click on the
support tab
found at the top right of your
presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the ask a
question box
located on the far left of your screen
i'd like to now introduce our presenters
dr margie morgan professor of pathology
and laboratory medicine
and scientific director and microbiology
cedar sinai medical center
and also dr tony beavers microbiology
solutions consultant
with bd for a complete biography on our
presenters
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your page
dr morgan and dr beavers you may now
begin your presentation
thank you very much muhammad it's really
nice to be speaking to everyone today
and particularly speak about something
that's just not directly related to
covet
but it's really not completely unrelated
antimicrobial stewardship really does
play a role
even in our time of covid because i
think all of you at least we have
started seeing a bit of increase in
antimicrobial resistance
because so many antibiotics are being
used this time
so i'm happy to be here today to share
with you
what our expanding role of microbiology
should be
in antimicrobial stewardship
these are my disclosures that you can
view
and we'll get started with the topic
so why is antimicrobial stewardship
important
well there's really many benefits that
can be seen to the health care system
of stewardship it can actually lead to
improved patient
outcomes it can reduce adverse events
including rates of clostridies difficile
infection
the rates of c diff of course are very
very important to follow and using
proper stewardship can really help
control your rates it can also optimize
resource utilization across the
continuum of care
including the microbiology laboratory
even though we might be
spending a bit more money in some
situations in some circumstances
in the end if you have good stewardship
and good use of antimicrobials
will end up decreasing costs across the
board
it also can help to prevent increasing
rates of resistance to antibiotics
these are the urgent resistance threats
to the public welfare that cd has listed
on their website
and i think that probably all of us have
dealt with some of these at a time or
two
we've had issues here at cedars with
carbopenum resistant acetobacter
canada rs has not raised its ugly head
yet here at cedars but it has certainly
in the los angeles area
clostridiorde's difficile is an ongoing
issue at cedars every day
we're starting to see more cre intro
bacterialis
and thank god we have not yet seen drug
resistant neisseria gonorrhea
but of course it's something that we're
always aware of that could come our way
these are the serious and concerning
resistance threats
that cdc has listed on their website
you can view through this list and say
oh yes
we have also seen some of these i have
to admit one of the biggest issues we
have currently been seeing at cedars is
multi-drug resistant pseudomonas
aerogenosa
so slowly but surely a lot of these drug
resistant things are becoming a part of
our daily operations
so the overuse and misuse of antibiotics
are major reasons for the increasing
rates of resistance that we are seeing
in our bacteria
and fungi and so of course this has led
to the federal mandate for hospitals to
engage in antimicrobial
stewardship there's core elements of the
hospital antibiotic stewardship programs
that we're all supposed to be
enacting in our medical centers so i'm
going to briefly discuss
some of these so the first one of course
is you need to have a commitment of your
hospital leadership
they need to makes to
provide funding for proper personnel
money for information technology
resources
so much of stewardship is driven by data
you truly do need a huge computer
operation on board to be able to assist
you
and this all takes leadership commitment
to supply the funds
how about accountability well you
certainly need to have a leader for
stewardship
it's usually a physician or a response a
pharmacist that is responsible for the
program management and outcomes
at our medical center we have infectious
disease physicians that are in charge of
our program
but it could vary in other institutions
it might be a pharmacist
that heads your stewardship whether you
have a pharmacist in charge of
stewardship or not you do need to
appoint
a pharmacist or a group of pharmacists
that are stewardship
dedicated and this can truly help
move your program forward and can lead
implementation efforts to improve
antibiotic use
there needs to be action in your
stewardship you can't just say you have
a program
in place and do nothing of course so you
need to implement
interventions such as audits and
feedback authorization to approve
antibiotic use or some other kind of
active
interaction to make sure that everyone
is aware
of what they should be doing and how
they should be using antibiotics
we get back to data tracking and
data is very important we need to
monitor
antibiotic prescribing the impact of
interventions are changes really being
made for the better
and other important outcomes such as our
rates of c
difficile infections and our ongoing
resistance
patterns we also need to have reporting
mechanisms
we need we need to regularly report
information on antibiotic use
and resistance to our prescribers so
they know what antibiotics are best for
certain circumstances
and we need to report to our pharmacists
our nurses and our hospital leadership
how all of our stewardship program is is
moving forward in education with all of
our programs
education is so terribly important we
need to educate our prescribers our
pharmacists
nurses and patients about adverse
reactions from antibiotics
ongoing issues with antibiotic
resistance and optimal prescribing
practices
so there's the outline of stewardship
program but my goodness microbiology
can't do all of this
so what is microbiology's role in
antimicrobial
stewardship the way i view this is our
mandatory role
is that we must prepare a yearly
hospital-wide anti-antibiogram
and to list all of our most common
organisms in their resistance pattern
and this is very important for our
stewardship group to be able to prepare
empiric therapy guidelines for our
institution
of course it is also mandatory that the
microbiology laboratory
test and restrictively report
antibiotics determined by stewardship
as appropriate and this is an ongoing
yearly process or maybe even more common
than yearly
to make sure that we're testing and
reporting the proper antibiotics
what can we do in addition well we could
provide
rapid diagnostics to guide rapid
escalation and de-escalation of therapy
we could also participate in quality
management programs
to improve the utilization of
antibiotics
this might be starting a procalcitonin
testing program in the laboratory
start a reflex urine culture algorithm
so where you only perform cultures when
suggestive of infection
tracking your c diff rates and
restricting antibiotic usage to improve
the rates
comments adding comments and reports to
educate which
patches pathogen might represent
contamination
this has been a very useful recent
addition that we've had to our program
of course we worked very closely with
the stewardship committee
to make sure that the reports that we
are writing and putting into our reports
met their criteria as well and of course
we need to ensure
timely reporting of our blood cultures
an important part of stewardship of
course is the diagnosis of sepsis
and that then becomes a lot or if not
all
about the blood culture so timely blood
culture reports are very important
empiric antimicrobial therapy given in
to the
before you have the blood culture
results is frequently inappropriate
and can sometimes cause increased
morbidity and mortality
prolonged hospitalization and increased
cost
so you want to really speed up your
blood cultures as often you know as much
as you can
so that their patients are not on
empiric therapy for a very long length
of time
decreasing the time between collection
of blood cultures and reportable results
have been shown by many reports to be
associated with
optimal therapy improved patient
outcomes
decreased hospital costs so
what actions can we take in the
microbiology to
try to reach this goal of decreasing the
time of collection of blood cultures and
reportable results
well the first thing we can do is make
our blood cultures as sensitive as we
can
this can be very helpful of course in
producing a good
and timely result on our blood cultures
one of the key determinants of the
sensitivity of blood cultures is the
volume of blood that is sampled
i know this is always a great
frustration for most laboratories
because we're
not necessarily in charge of the people
that are collecting our blood cultures
but in the perfect world we should
collect at least two sets of blood
cultures
collected per septic episode in an adult
and of course the higher the blood
volume uh cultured
the higher the yield the volume of the
blood
collected must be monitored and
education efforts made to collect the
recommended volume
we of course have systems if you have
bacter systems you know that there's a
way to monitor the volume of blood
in the back tech some laboratories
actually monitor them as they come into
the laboratory
but there needs to be some way to
monitor
the different areas of the hospital and
how they are doing their collection of
blood and the volume that they're
collecting
and it's really very important that this
is part
of a continued quality monitoring
program in the microbiology laboratory
so we have it as an ongoing program and
for reporting and education to the units
that are not meeting standards
every laboratory can set up a program
that best suits their needs
and with their computer capabilities
that they might have
but you really do need to check the
different areas of the
hospital and check monthly and see how
they're doing and then of course go back
and re-educate
if they're not collecting the proper
volumes
what about blood culture contamination
well each laboratory also needs to
establish a quality management plan to
achieve a blood culture contamination
rate
below the national benchmark of less
than or equal to three percent
this has been the benchmark that we've
been working with for years
but there's been so many publications
recently
promoting trying to keep pushing and
pushing to get this benchmark lower
because there's nothing that leads to
more misuse or overuse of antimicrobials
than having treatment for contaminated
blood cultures
so there's several things that we can do
i'm only listing a few
you could probably give me even better
ideas possibly but
you could switch from iodine to
chlorhexidine scrubs that's one thing
and that totally helped us lower our
rates of contamination
there's also a lot of new devices that
are on the market
that can assist with providing you more
clean draws
they might add some expense to your
drawing
of blood cultures but there's nothing
more expensive
than having elongated hospital stays
due to blood culture contamination that
has led to overuse of antimicrobials
and over treatment and exposure to
antibiotics when it's not necessary
also we've had ongoing programs in our
hospital for improved care of catheter
line hubs
such as using alcohol hub caps to
prevent those
out those on catheter hubs from just
dangling
all over the patient's beds and such and
then not being cleaned
adequately prior to blood draw
rates also trend lower with a dedicated
phlebotomy staff
that draws your blood cultures we're not
so fortunate to have that at cedars we
do have e.d
nursing personnel and also nurse
collections on the floor
doing some of our blood culture
collection but it has been shown
in many papers that if you have a
dedicated phlebotomy team
you're probably going to trend toward
lower contamination rates
also an ongoing program must be in place
to monitor contamination rate
this has even become a a cap
cap inspection question and so it's very
important that we monitor
our blood culture contamination and
report back to units
that are not um that are failing
our contamination threshold
so now what comprises a contaminant
well it can be very difficult these days
to accurately the differentiation of
what organism
is a contaminant it's become more
difficult
as patients have become more complicated
for both the clinician with treatment
decisions
and for the laboratory calculating
contamination rates
i think we've all seen gram-positive
bacteria
causing true sepsis increase over the
last decade or so
of course staff epidermidis and our
other coag negative staff
they're no longer only contaminants so
there needs to be
a multi-disciplinary approach with your
stewardship
group and others to determine criteria
for what is actually considered a
contaminant
and you need to i think add comments to
your report
to inform of possible contamination when
you're reporting blood cultures
and this really drives that message home
is even though this grew something
there please take a second look there is
a true possibility
that this growth in the blood culture
could be due to skin contamination
and as i said contamination can lead to
a major resource utilization issue
and can lead to massive overuse of
antibiotics
so it's really very important of course
that we all
look at our contamination rates closely
and do our best to lower them
so how can we provide overall rapid
results to help out our antimicrobial
stewardship group
in our patient care situation well in a
perfect
world we're going to do blood cultures
collection in a timely and efficient way
and then they're going to be rapidly
transported to the laboratory
cultures will then be directly placed
into
automated blood culture instrumentation
we rapidly respond to a positive alert
in the automated instrument and we
perform our gram stain
quickly to give results to our
clinicians and caregivers
these results are communicated and
explained to a physician
in a timely fashion we will do our rapid
molecular diagnostic tests
rapidly and then we will um following
that
complete organism identification and
susceptibility
as rapidly as possible this is
the the perfect world we can aim to
achieve this
some of these things are actually a
little bit out of our control
but in the perfect world this is the
best thing that we could possibly do to
turn around
rapid blood culture results
also at the same time we're trying to do
all of this performance we can do rapid
molecular diagnostics
that can perhaps give our physicians and
caregivers
useful information there's a variety of
different
products on the market now to be able to
do
molecular testing to provide this
information
there's nucleic acid amplification based
methods for both id
and resistance markers there's insight
in situ hybridization based methods for
id
such as the pna fish and quick fish
although this is ending
this at the end of the year i believe
these products may be going off the
market
there's phenotypic susceptibilities
using such systems as the accelerate
there's mass spectral methods of course
using maldi tof that can provide
very rapid identification magnetic
residence based methods such as t2
biosystems
that can supply id and resistance marker
testing from whole blood
and metagenomic shotgun sequencing
methods
for searching out bacteria fungi and
viruses
so there's a variety of rapid molecular
diagnostics
available on the market and so it's for
ours
for us to choose which one might work
best
in supporting our stewardship efforts
can rapid molecular diagnostic tests
improve patient care
well i do think they can improve patient
care certainly
and they can provide some very valuable
information
but as i'm going to say it's not going
to necessarily be the end-all
and the only information that is going
to be needed or helpful
so molecular diagnostic techniques that
detect pathogens
and antimicrobial resistance genes can
be a tremendous benefit
to timely diagnosis and management of
sepsis
however overall they vary inability to
assist with proper therapy choices
depending upon the organism
identification
and if a resistance marker is actually
detected
so for the gram positives identification
of gram positive bacteria
is usually can be quite helpful for
therapy choices
and the if it is particularly paired
with
resistance genes such as a mec a that
can provide
very useful information for the
caregivers
to make alterations in antimicrobial
therapy
but the gram negatives gives you a
little bit different picture sometimes
with just rapid molecular
tests now if you're just doing
identification alone
on a gram-negative organism depending
upon your own hospital in your own
patient population
having identification may not be
adequate information
to change therapy choices
just knowing it's an e coli is that
really all you need to know to make
drastic changes in antimicrobial therapy
most people would say perhaps not
some emerging resistance mechanisms also
are not detected
by some of the rapid molecular
diagnostic tests
such as the amp c gene in enterogram
negative rods
or porin alterations and efflux pumps
in pseudomonas aerogenosa so although
these molecular diagnostic tests can
help
in some circumstances uh change help to
improve antimicrobial usage they're not
the end all
and not the end result you need more
information
so how about these rapid molecular tests
it's complicated
a survey of non-id physicians concerning
the understanding of rapid molecular
blood culture identification panel
results showed that 60 percent of them
said that they did adjust therapy
based on rapid molecular results
for the blood culture identification and
molecular markers
however only 53 percent correctly
de-escalated therapy based on rapid
molecular results for
say methicillin sensitive staph aureus
so what's going on here you gave them
the results but it seems like they
didn't
use them properly so in a recent survey
that was done
two and three believe of id physicians
that were surveyed
believe that these newer diagnostic
tests are becoming a little bit too
complex
for the non-id physicians to fully
understand
and the most unmet diagnostic need is
really prompt identification
of drug resistant aerobic gram-negative
bacilli
the other thing that i think is very
important and for what i said on the
last slide
there's a lot of misunderstanding
and maybe miscommunication of some of
these results
so i i bring a quote here a rapid
diagnostic test result that remains
unchecked in the medical record
is the tree that falls in the forest
with no one around to hear it
so not only are they perhaps not
understanding it
i think at times they're not even
viewing it
because we if um if we just put some of
these rapid results into the computer
it's not necessarily saying that the
physician is going to take a look at it
and so we've wasted some very expensive
health care resources
in and potential leading to delayed
optimization of care
they could have done a lot of good if
the physician had looked at them but
sometimes it could be 24 hours or more
before some of this information is
actually viewed by the md
so i think the point i'm driving home
here is that
it's it's really very worthwhile and
wonderful
that microbiology laboratories are
performing some of these very rapid
methods
but unless we combine that with
real-time communication
by phone text or web page with these
results
it and you really don't have a good
comprehensive stewardship program
i really think you need to to have a
program
where you produce these results and then
you
communicate with the clinician via phone
text or web page
and provide an explanation of the
information
by to an antimicrobial pharmacist
to the physician to someone to be able
to
take care of the patient correctly and i
think that's a very important
part of performing these rapid tests
so keeping up with increasing resistance
despite the ability of rapid methods
to identify some of the key pathogens
and resistance genes
as i said none of these methods in
isolation alone
have shown diagnostic accuracy to the
extent
that they can be used as the sole
microbiological information for therapy
you cannot get around that a
well-performed antimicrobial
susceptibility
with multiple antimicrobial options is
still the powerhouse
and this is what microbiology performs
and we provide this powerhouse
i think it's particularly important
for the gram negative rods at least in
my particular facility
and i think also i just have to say that
i think keeping up
with gram negative rod antimicrobial
resistance has been particularly
challenging in our laboratory
so much has been going on recently we've
had updates to all the break points to
help us support improved resistance
detection
for esbls and cpos but
because of that we've had to go back and
revalidate all the break points and
there's been a great deal of work
and you've really had to to put a great
deal of time in doing
all of this properly and then no sooner
do you get that done then
then you're starting to see more of the
resistant organisms and you have to
bring in new panels and new ways
to test new antibiotics and they require
validation of new panels or new test
strips or new disks
so there's just keeping up with
antimicrobial resistance particularly
for the gram negative rods
i think has been a major challenge
so the way we've approached it is we've
used
a combination of maldi tof and the bd
phoenix for doing our susceptibility
testing
we get rapid ids of course using maldi
tof
and we switched over to the bd phoenix
emerge panels which offer a very broad
selection
of antibiotics and information
it provides confirmatory esbl tests
you get the also a cpo detect test what
i'll talk about in a moment
and you get a lot of therapeutic options
for treating the seep
the carbapenemas producing organisms
gives you a very broad list of
antibiotics
i've put in the boxes the ones that are
ones that are moving are being more
often used
for cpos and it does give you
a very nice panel with a very thorough
information for the clinicians and the
stewardship pharmacists to use for
therapy
and this has proved very useful for us
now what is this bd phoenix cpo detect
test
well i think that at least we have and i
think i can say that most microbiology
laboratories
have struggled with the proper detection
and characterization
of some of the producing organisms
so this bd phoenix cpo detect test
is a qualitative confirmatory growth
based test
that's in the gram-negative panel for
detection
and confirmation of class a b and d
carbapenemases so it uses maripenum
and doripenum tamoxillin and cloxicillin
alone and in different combinations with
all sorts of various chelators and
beta-lactamase inhibitor
inhibitors and works together
to provide us a test for the
classification
of the carbapenemase and this can really
help you
detect those in the intraobacterialis
the pseudomonas aerogenosa
and the acinetobacter bomanii so
this could have a very positive impact
on your laboratory workflow and on
therapeutic
impact and infection control decisions
because you're
more accurately detecting carbopentamise
producing organisms
so in summary the antimicrobial
stewardships
should be a very coordinated program
that promotes the appropriate use of
antibiotics
and such programs should be administered
by multi-disciplinary teams
composed of infectious disease
physicians clinical pharmacists
clinical microbiologists and infection
control practitioners
and should be actively supported by
hospital administrators
i think you should learn to and become
partners with these people make them
your best friends
they can be so helpful and they have
been so helpful to us
in moving forward major projects within
microbiology
we should be very proud because the
microbiology laboratory plays a very
important role in stewardship
by providing identification and
susceptibility data that drives
therapeutic decisions for the optimum
care of patients
and the optimum use of antibiotics
so i will end those with my words and
now i will
let you let dr tony beavers take over
as the second part of our discussion
about the
laboratory role in antimicrobial
stewardship
i give to you dr tony beavers
thank you dr morgan um
i am employed by bd integrated
diagnostic solutions as a microbiology
solutions consultant at the disclosure
and the content related to clinical
cases are a result of my published
research and certainly my opinions
the purpose in our discussion to
continue today is
the to discuss the clinical laboratory's
role in providing applicable and
actionable
information that improves our processes
in healthcare delivery
clinical responsiveness and health
outcomes while respecting
financial constraints our objectives
are to review the burden of sepsis and
anatomical resistance as examples of
collaborative focus
describe capabilities of clinical
laboratory scientists and
microbiologists in the continuum of
health care
and understand limitations of diagnostic
tests and how to convey to our expect
holders as well as a couple of case
studies
so first we're going to begin by
addressing the health and financial
burdens associated with sepsis and just
to continue what dr
morgan mentioned certainly globally
there's an estimated 31.5 million cases
of sepsis with 5.3 million
deaths each year clinical studies and
certainly have demonstrated a two-fold
increase in mortality caused by sepsis
when inappropriate antimicrobial therapy
is given
we know that that's visually cause of
death and critical illness globally with
hospital mortality rates of about 25 to
30 percent
and as again as dr morgan mentioned
blood culture remains a critical tool in
the management of sepsis
within the laboratory system
so and another i guess key statistic is
sepsis is
the uh number one leading cause of death
in hospitals
um you know again we're talking about
the united states here
there's approximately 270 000 people
died from sepsis each year
representing a financial burden of over
62 billion
we also know that sepsis incidence is
rising to a staggering eight percent
increase every year
as we identify causative organisms from
septic patients
another key impact driver and
opportunity for collaborative focus
within antimicrobial stewardship
programs
is effectively detecting antimicrobial
resistance unfortunately
as we head to 2050 the projections
include approximately 10
million deaths that have cost of over
100
trillion per year
so basically as laboratorians we already
have an impact on antimicrobial
stewardship
and clinical responsiveness first we can
assess what we do
how we do it and how we can help our
stakeholders for the remainder of the
presentation we'll consider each one of
these following stakeholders and provide
some potential ways to expand our role
while we go about our daily activities
within the laboratory
again as dr morgan has already mentioned
one of the most familiar ways that
impact ams is by using antibiograms
traditionally these are only produced
yearly or annually we can certainly
expand our repertoire of antibiograms by
using a more focused approach
during my previous basement laboratory
as mrsa became more prevalent
we were tasked with more frequent
antibiograms focused on clinical
conditions to guide
outpatient therapy options so for
instance this is an example of a very
specific
antibiogram reviewing outpatients that
presented with skin and soft tissue
infections
um contributing specifically to staff we
were frequently asked to provide
customized antibiograms for cystic
fibrosis
hemoglobin patients and even
healthcare-associated infections
this is another example we used for
antimicrobial stewardship program in
empiric therapy considerations
knowing organism incidents helped inform
our clinical colleagues for optimal
decision making
the screenshot presents organism
incidents isolated
again from skin soft tissue cultures
from pediatric patients presenting to
our
ed we use a similar approach to focus on
our burn unit and icus
as organism incidence reports can also
be a first
step in determining which organisms may
be relevant for patient
patient population specific antibiograms
that seemed to be really a conundrum for
me in the past
is okay what exactly what organisms do i
need to include
on my antibiogram every year and so an
incidence report test is very very
helpful in that
purpose
as the laboratorians will also receive
special requests from our infection
prevention and public health partners
this is an example of using an organism
trending graph
that helped our colleagues measure and
track an outbreak of shigella sonia
using real-time data
we also said an alert system to notify
infection preventionists by smartphone
whenever we had an increase in cases or
whenever
cases met a certain threshold and the
the cool thing is is the threshold can
be very dynamic
so as seasons change and as other
events occur within the community change
this can be a moving target and of
course using software
we use the vdf center for that of course
you know we can migrate
with those necessary changes
so basically if we look at global
healthcare new challenges are taking
shape
we see evolving technologies as dr
morgan mentioned certainly with um
genetic and phenotypic news technologies
we also see rising bacterial resistance
and as we start to consider these new
technologies we should ask ourselves
that these technologies can keep up
with evolving resistance and our
communication mechanisms
enabled to again provide this accurate
information
timely to our healthcare partners as
described earlier
for instance how do we handle
carbohydrates producing organisms also
known as cpos
while managing our resources
within the laboratory
why is testing for cpos important even
though cpus are typically low incidence
path engines
one single index case can certainly
spread to multiple facilities within a
relatively short time
and unfortunately go unnoticed early
detection may help in reducing
transmission
a real-time alert system within the
laboratory can certainly provide a more
rapid notification
especially if you practice cascade
reporting or suppression of antibiotics
that's typically an alert system at the
hospital information level
or at the laboratory information level
may not capture
resistance if the antibiotic is
suppressed at the
at the laboratory level
so let's take one step further why is
routine testing for cpos important
um when comparing infections from
protein and resistant organisms to
infections from non-resistant organisms
there is a three-fold more chance that
the infected patient is on an
inappropriate empiric therapy
and those patients traditionally have a
12 higher mortality rate
they stay in the hospital longer which
certainly contributes to more health
care dollars spent
these factors not only concern us as
laboratories but also impact our
clinicians
our pharmacists infection preventionists
healthcare
quality professionals as well as
hospital financial controllers
unfortunately we're all affected by
these statistics and you know not just
certainly our patients
so when we assess our scope of detecting
emerging resistance and technological
capabilities within the lab
we also consider that no system products
instrument is perfect as a normal
progression of bringing on these new
technologies
and actually investigating these new
technologies um during the validation
and verification process
we have the opportunity to help our
stakeholders understand these
limitations
and be able to discuss all of these
hopefully prior to bringing on these
tests
so that we assess the relevancy within
our patient population
and certainly in my previous lab days we
use the following communications
strategically and modified as tech
technologies evolved
and of course it's a fixing comments
it's serving as consultants
educating your infectious disease rounds
we had other ways too
we we had actually a fun workshop
situation and where pharmacists
and clinical laboratory scientists were
included in annual or twice a year
workshops
so this regional and statewide
collaborative workshops with pharmacy
and laboratorians
were so productive and and again they
were so much fun
the pharmacist reviewed and set up kirby
bowers and mic
tests and our clinical laboratory
scientists learned from the pharmacist
about
pharmacokinetics and pharmacodynamics
and the critical need of lower brake
break points in clinical care so we
basically just kind of understood
the other end of antimicrobial
stewardship
and again we had a lot of fun doing in
doing so
so now to just a couple of very brief
case studies
um and how we use this rapid reporting
system
relative antimicrobial stewardship
so one example from my previous life
experience using collaborative focus was
a project we took on to reduce
vancomycin use
this objective came down from the
c-suite and required us to use real-time
alerting to manage vancomycin
interventions specifically my ceo
walked into my office and said tony i
want you to meet dr maples dr maples i
want you to meet tony you're going to be
best friends
um we needed lower bank of mice and
youth
so we kind of sat down and talked about
how we were going to do this
for a very brief and quick look at
this approach we actually looked at 49
patients
where we used the bd epicenter and the
fentanyl model
to set up real-time alerts for
inpatients with staff aureus
we sent those alerts to the pharmacist
the clinical pharmacist's phone
as a result of the real-time alerting we
were able to obtain
mrsa mssa results within the same shift
um and in doing so we were able to
optimize vacuum often dosing
we were able to decrease vancomycin use
and certainly decrease
over overall time to target target
therapy
and kind of as a sidebar we were able to
decrease time to
infection prevention management for mrsa
patients
while still saving time due to the
optimization of the laboratory workflow
using these automatic results
and alerts
another example of the impact of
real-time reporting occurred when we had
a patient admitted to our burn unit with
mdr
acetobacter as a result of the alert
system within the bdfe center
we were able to initiate appropriate
empiric therapy and infection prevention
management sooner
and we initially installed it as soon as
the index case presented to our hospital
um so after that was initiated with the
first case
and we used the collaborative focus of
course a real-time alert was sent to
pharmacy infection prevention
and infectious disease with different
reasons so for instance
one alert went to the infection
preventionist and they were able to do
one-on-one
nursing care compact precautions while
simultaneously the same alert went to
the clinician so that they could modify
therapy
and then at that point it became a
reportable disease so
it came to the infection preventionist
as well as myself so that we could
report to the health department
and basically this process eliminated
multiple phone calls
and saved our staff and certainly our
patients critical time
so basically how to measure success you
know in this day and age you know we do
wonderful things
um but it seems like we're being tasked
and passed um with measuring that
success and reporting that success
so um you know
collaboratively you know we do things
wonderful together
but still separately it seems that we
are
tasked with uh different metrics
so for instance in the pharmacy the
traditional metric in the pharmacy may
be antibiotic costs or days of use
so for vancomycin vancomycin is cheap so
it could be how many bank days per 1 000
patient days
a few percent of bacteria is more
expensive so it might be actually annual
cost
quarterly cost and also time to target
therapy
you know for instance with a clinic
clinical pharmacist able to decrease
time to target therapy in certain
patient populations and and another kind
of newer metric
is called days of therapy avoided so
those are our pharmacy partners
traditional measures to success uh
for antimicrobial stewardship now the
laboratory some of these may be for us
is how many different tests are you
doing did you start off with three
different tests to measure
and oxycontoxide testing and now you're
down to one you know that's great
um how much time does it take to set up
a test
um average cost per test or average cost
per pathogen may be another
measure for affection preventionist
traditional measurements or central line
days per 1000 patient days
um certainly healthcare associated
infections
isolation days for 1000 patient days and
again our friends and our
our health care system also for quality
measures look at length of stay
mortality rate reimbursement
and certainly the hospital acquired
condition hack scores by the cms
is another measure
so um today we certainly hope we've
given you some ideas on how to enhance
your antimicrobial stewardship
capabilities
within the clinical laboratory while
conserving resources and working with
our partners
it's certainly within our reach by
incorporating small but meaningful
changes
now how do we measure success certainly
collaboratively of course
um and now we're actually at our
question and answer
phase and mo would you like to take it
over
thank you tony and uh thank you to dr
morgan also
for your informative presentations we
will now start the live q a portion of
the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box on
the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions many of
your questions as we have time
so with that let's get started
uh for dr morgan at the beginning of the
presentation he talked
very briefly about the impact of covet
19
specific to antimicrobial resistance can
you talk a little bit more about your
experience
if kobe 19 and antimatter resistance and
what lesson does any we can take from
the pandemic about combating myanmar
um certainly it's a very good question i
think
two things were happening at least our
our medical center
particularly early on during the covet
pandemic
and that was a lot of people were
delaying
hospitalization trips they were
perhaps not doing well at home but they
were reluctant to come into the hospital
so they were showing up at the hospital
when they were really quite ill
and therefore some of them were
requiring antimicrobials and perhaps
wouldn't have if they'd shown up earlier
but a lot of people were being put on
antimicrobial therapy
at the same time we were getting a very
high census of covid patients
that had of course a lot of respiratory
and lung
issues and they were all being treated
for the possibility of secondary
bacterial infections
so it just seemed like for a very long
period of time we had a lot of people
on very high dose of antibiotics and i
do not think we're unique i think this
has been the situation
so the combination of high use of
antibiotics over a long period of time
and that can certainly lead to acquired
resistance
also transmission of organisms i think
that
during some of this time there were so
many coveted fears and coveted
precautions and
coveted protocols being put in place
that
we did a bit and i've heard from other
institutions as well that there was
possibly more
transmission of organisms than you would
have liked to have seen
so you put all that together and there
just seems to be a little bit more
resistance moving around our hospitals
these days
thank you um next question
and this is for both of our speakers
with your lab experience and your time
in the lab what recommendations would
you give
to an organization that uh early on in
their
partnership with antimicrobial
stewardship and as a second part to that
question
how can the microbiology lab become more
involved or a better partner
to antimicrobial stewardship programs so
i'll ask
dr tony beavers first and then dr morgan
if you could chime in as well
thanks muhammad um so it was actually
getting to talk to one another and so i
literally sat down with our
clinical pharmacist our chief of
infectious disease we set over coffee
and we figured out
you know what what is the number one
objective that we need to do we had to
make it simple so we didn't have a lot
of funding actually we had no funding we
had very little
um personnel resources and i didn't want
to
certainly increase the time in our
laboratory
so the only singular function that we
were able
to initiate was vancomycin and actually
was the most powerful it was it was an
incredible
journey and and we learned a lot so
basically just sitting down
um talking with our partners and asking
you know
what what is the easiest simplest thing
that we can do
to make the biggest impact
um if you're finished dr weavers i'll
say that i think the one thing that has
been
the greatest advantage for me over the
last um 10 years or so
is really becoming good friends
with my pharmacist my id physician that
are on stewardship as well as in
infection control and really
making a good partnership and being able
to use them
for assistance i can
we've become very close and they need me
as much as i need them and we've worked
together in trying to make policies and
procedures
and i do not think that microbiology
laboratories can be in their own silo
and not be directly involved with their
stewardship committee it's really
you can learn a great deal from them and
they will learn that they can learn a
great deal from the microbiology
laboratories as well
and it's it's truly a group effort
great thank you we have time for a few
more questions i just want to remind our
audience that those questions that we're
unable to answer today and those that
come in
during the on-demand period we will
answer
or the speakers will answer the email
address
that you provide at the time of
registration so
that will move into some additional
questions here
for dr weavers you spoke about the
alerting system in bdf
center that enabled early notification
of clinicians for critical organisms
are there other capabilities in your
experience with the bd phoenix system
to help support ams initiatives
wow um great question um so
as we progress through our antimicrobial
stewardship goals is we did find some
additional um advantages and
we practiced cascade reporting so for
instance if the fazlin was susceptible
we didn't cascade to the second third
and fourth generation syphilis foreign
and so we did that we also suppressed la
nasalit and after myosin and whatnot
but if we suppress that the problem is
it didn't go to the lis
and so we had additional software that
would not get through
um so we did use um the epicenter and
fentanyl to alert us when we had
situations of non-susceptible linaselid
or
um cases of previously um
clustered and organisms so such as we
had serrated marcessa's in our nursery
at one point
so we had an alert in the background
mining that
um in case that came up again so
anything that
we needed to be alerted about because if
we
if infection prevention needed
one-on-one nursing care or contact
precautions
or any reportable disease those are the
things that went to the infection
preventionist
and anything i needed for clsi
follow-up or if i needed to freeze the
organism or if they're process
if i need to do some fingerprinting or
whatnot that was all going behind the
scenes in surveillance
without the technologist even knowing
about that so they didn't have to worry
about not
catching a certain scenario there was
another case of
our cystic fibrosis population their
first isolate of
um phenomonal theragenosa and all
isolated vocal area sepatia
all of those were alerted to our chief
of pulmonology
and our nurse practitioner for
pulmonology
okay great we have a
more specific question here that i'll
open it up to both of our speakers
can procalcitonin used in conjunction
with molecular resistant markers
be used to reduce mdr pseudomonas or
acetobacter infection
and do you think that's a practical idea
or suggestion for smaller diagnostic
facilities
dr beavers you want to take that one i
all i can say is
i think that in our medical center we
have a 950 bed facility at cedars
we've had variable
abuse well we've had variable success
with our procalcitonin program
and i think that um perhaps in a better
setting a better
use of the program you could use it in
that case
i would say in our institution we would
not have success
doing that but dr beavers might have a
very different look on that so
take it away dr beavers okay
and you know back to i would recommend
looking at your patient population
and almost even doing like a little
pilot study
to look at um you know
how how does this behave in your patient
population
um it may be effective and it may not um
again depends on where you
are in the country what type of patients
that you see um
so if you know pro calculus is not a
magic bullet but it certainly may be
effective
within your patient population but you
know there's only one way to kind of
understand that and that's how to do a
little bit of pilot study or
you know do a little bit of research on
that before you walk through a
widespread initial
you know initiation throughout the
entire facility yeah i
don't you think dr beavers that has
proven procalcitonin's proven to be a
little bit trickier to use than people
initially thought
yes yes that's the point i'm trying to
make
we thought we had it in the bag and then
when we started using our program that
we thought would be wonderful it
didn't end up providing us the results
that we thought it might
okay so thank you again dr morgan dr
beavers before i say some closing words
do you have any final comments or
feedback for our audience
i have to say thank you for inviting me
to speak today
and i just can't say more about
finding partnerships and moving forward
in stewardship
it's a lonely world out there in
microbiology laboratory sometimes and we
have the support of our pharmacists
stewardship pharmacists in particular
infection control and
infectious disease people involved in
stewardship
it can just be a much easier easier
trip through trying to obtain our goals
of better use of antibiotics
yeah i absolutely agree with that 100
and i'd also
like to add that whenever it was time to
purchase
new technologies and new equipment i
always went to my clinical pharmacist to
my
infection prevention partners as well as
my infectious disease partners
and said i need this new equipment i
need this new technology you know we've
talked about it
you know here's how much it cost can you
help me do a
cost justification the total cost of
ownership
so that we can bring this on board for
our patients
so they can be your partner and whenever
you're seeking funds to bring on
you don't do this in a silo you know
they need you they need us in laboratory
and we're here to help but we have to
have that
support for um you know purchasing
capital equipment
and these newer technologies
okay great so before we go i'd like to
thank
the audience for joining us today and
their interesting questions
um any questions that we did not cover
and those submitted during the on demand
period
will be addressed by the speakers via
the contact information you provided
during time of registration
we'd like to once again thank dr morgan
and dr beavers for their time
today and their important work we'd also
like to thank
lab roots and bd for underwriting
today's educational webcast
you can view this webinar on demand lab
roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay
so with that i hope everyone has a great
rest of their friday and great weekend
until next time
goodbye thanks